le contexte sanitaire a repoussé la
sortie de leur film mais pas la
rencontre avec le public grâce à ses
adhérents soit là pas mal cette
initiative de dinde tout simplement noir
raconte l'histoire de jean pascal
un comédien qui veut lancer une marche
composé uniquement d'hommes noirs
il est au coeur d'un documentaire en
documentaire fictifs
on voulait vraiment ancré le truc dans
une réalité on voulait que ça paraisse
vrai quoi parce que voilà le truc qu'on
décrit les très actuelle donc du
documentaire permettait de l'allemand
faire quelque chose de plus réel
le film il un message assez universel
c'est une comédie qui essayent de voile
a décrypté pas mal de pas mal de choses
et comme le fond il est assez universel
on essaie juste de montrer que walaja il
n'ya pas réellement de communauté le
fait d'être noir ne fait pas de nous une
communauté et être noir finalement
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
le projet pensé depuis 2015 rassemble un
grand nombre de célébrités
un parti pris plein d'autodérision qui
trouve un écho particulier en pleine
affaire georges floyd et adama traoré
j'avais déjà ses questionnements là et
le fait que voilà
avec les événements qui sont passés ça
arrive au moment de la sortie ça veut
dire que c'est d'autant plus d'actualité
c'est un film nécessaire 80% qui est
écrit et bien sûr quand on a des mecs
comme farhi jonathan cohen ramzy fabrice
éboué on est très preneur de tout ce
qu'ils peuvent nous donner en comédien
dont quoi c'est comme ça qu'on allait
chercher donc fallait laisser une part
d'improvisation
sortie le 8 juillet dernier le film est
premier du box office en france avec
plus de 180 mille entrées